So, let's revisit what we are shooting for in the structure of an operating
system. We want the operating system strucure to be thin. That is, like a
microkernel. That is only mechanisms should be
in the kernel, and no policies should
be ingrained in the kernel itself. The
structure should allow fine-grained access to system
resources without border crossing, as much as possible. That is, it should
be like the DOS-like structure. That is, it should have a structure similar to
what we saw in DOS. And it should be flexible, meaning resource management
should be easily morphed to suit
the needs of the application without sacrificing
protection and performance. So, the flexibility part
of it should be similar to what
we can get from microkernel based approach, but at the same time we want the
protection and the performance we can get
with the monolithic approach. So in other words,
in a nutshell what we want in
the operating structure is performance, protection, and flexibility.